[Musique]
ces habitants viennent d'être évacués
par l'armée ukrainienne à châssivia a
une douzaine de kilomètres de barmouth
la plupart n'ont pris que le nécessaire
encore traumatisé d'avoir presque tous
les C derrière eux aucune des deux
armées n'arrivent à prendre le contrôle
de la ville les combats durs depuis
plusieurs mois et rendent la vie
totalement impossible
les gens nous appellent nous leur
donnons l'heure et ils préparent un
minimum d'affaires ensuite on les amène
ici ils sont placés dans les centres
spécialisés à partir de là ils peuvent
partir vers un autre endroit dans le
pays où ils seront en sécurité
d'après l'armée ukrainienne il resterait
entre 1000 et 5000 personnes dans la
ville qui en contenaient 70 000 avant
guerre
une partie des évacués a pu être
redirigée vers un autre centre loin des
combats loin des bombardements
quotidiens
c'est tellement de fois maman on part
maman on peut y aller moi j'étais un peu
naïve inquiète de quitter notre
appartement et là j'ai vu une roquette
volée au-dessus de la maison on est
parti précipitamment le centre avait été
mis en place il y a un mois barmot mais
devant la violence des combats l'endroit
était devenu trop dangereux
notre priorité est de nous réchauffer de
nous nourrir nous prenons une douche du
thé chaud du café on peut même prendre
un repas trois fois par jour
reste l'une des plus féroces batailles
de cette guerre en Ukraine pour qui elle
demeure un symbole de résistance pour
Moscou la prise de la ville serait une
avancée majeure bien que la plupart des
experts occidentaux refusent cette
hypothèse